i think what we really want is to be
useful we want to do work that matters
we don't want to do meaningless work it
drives humans crazy to do stuff we don't
care about but we all have this desire
to do stuff we want to contribute we
want to help people we want to do things
that we feel like are important
hold millet welcome to the show
excited to be here chris
i have been
fully adopted by texas now so i went to
a co-wetzel
country music
rock concert in a stadium last night
people unironically wearing cowboy hats
people unironically saying like dang and
yeehaw
i'm one of the locals now
i think i'm the same me and my wife uh
we're saying we still have to go to a
rodeo and then we can probably say that
there's like a sequence of
uh qualifications or trials that you
need to go through yeah yeah precisely
how many cans of lone star have you
drank how many times have you said the
word dang
exactly yeah we love it here it seems
like there's a
convergence of internet weirdos and
hyper curious
kind of creators uh that i've just
really enjoyed well the first time that
we met was at the uh less wrong meetup
which is that's the nerdiest part that's
the synthesis yeah that's the [ __ ]
epicenter that's patient zero for the
nerdiest people in austin and they'd
even imported people from outside of
austin to make it significantly more
nerdy
exactly
yeah it's been great i love it here one
of the things that we've both been
converging on was something that i put
into my newsletter this week and i want
to talk about that so i'm going to read
the newsletter out for people that
didn't read it if you haven't read it go
to chriswilex.com books and you can sign
up for free uh so one of the most common
tensions i talk about at the moment is
between a desire for success and a
desire to feel like we're enough success
is a strange thing presumably we want
success because we think a more
successful life will bring us more
happiness meaning and fulfillment here's
the problem we sacrifice the thing we
want happiness for the thing which is
supposed to get it success
failure can make you miserable but i'm
not sure success will make you happy one
of the most common dynamics i see
amongst high performers is this parents
want their child to do well parents
encourage their child to do well by
praising them when they succeed and
criticizing when they fail the child
learns that praise and admiration is
contingent on succeeding that lesson
metastasizes through early adulthood
into i am only worthy of love and
acceptance and belonging if i succeed
now powered by an internal feeling of
insufficiency this person is driven to
achieve many things they're prepared to
outwork out hustle and out suffer
everyone else because they're not just
running toward a life they want they're
running away from a life that they fear
success and progress ameliorates the
feelings of insufficiency therefore
success and progress become prioritized
above everything else now don't get me
wrong many high achievers genuinely love
the work that they do and many are
driven by a well-balanced simple desire
to maximize their time on this planet
rather than trying to fill a void inside
of themselves but if i was to place a
bet i'd guess that the majority of high
performers are driven by fears of
insufficiency rather than a holistic
desire to be better i think people who
are high achievers on average are more
miserable than the average person so
what does it mean that the people we
most admire are the ones with the least
admirable internal states if the pursuit
of success is in an effort to make us
happy and in the pursuit of success we
make ourselves miserable why not
shortcut the entire process and just be
happy is that even possible now external
accolades do count for a lot i don't
think that recanting all worldly
possessions and retreating to a cave in
the woods is an optimal strategy some
degree of external material success is
important to make us feel validated and
satiate our desire for status and
respect
but
external success won't fill an internal
void
insufficiency insufficiency adaptation
is this
if your drive to succeed comes from a
fear of insufficiency and you continue
to disprove those fears with success in
the real world and yet the feelings of
insufficiency persists what makes you
think that the answer to this problem is
more success there's no clean answer
here the world is messy and we're
hopelessly irrational you don't need to
let go of all success goals but spend
some time working out whether there's a
shorter route to the life you want by
removing obstacles rather than just
pressing harder on the accelerator
i love it it sounds like you're uh on
the pathless path now uh basically what
i've written about but
uh i think this is such a fascinating
topic because it sort of describes my
own journey i went from somebody that
was what i call trying to get ahead
you're aiming at a future potential
success and you're saying okay i'm
willing to sacrifice and then now to get
there the problem is you never arrive
right and the funny thing is i didn't
have the parents praising me or
criticizing me for achieving or not
achieving goals
i fully
brought this upon myself
in college i was just around people who
had those parents and i was like ooh
they want all these things i want what
they want right classic mimetic desire
and i did that for the next
12 13 years
until
i just slowly more reflection and more
reflection realize
holy crap this isn't me
i thought it was like 10 percent
different than those people around me
strategy consultants high achievers in
the corporate world i was probably one
or two standard deviations little
different in terms of what are the
elements of
life that are going to bring me alive
and connect me to who i am
what were the biggest differences
i think i have an unreasonable need for
autonomy and freedom over my life the
things i do the ideas i work on and how
i do it
most people are willing to sacrifice a
lot of those things
in exchange for like security and a
paycheck
right i
was not pricing
that appropriately i didn't get as big a
benefit
and i was paying bigger costs for like
what i was giving up
the problem and the reason i stayed on
my previous path so long was that i
didn't have an imagination of a
different possible life
my only model of the world was work hard
get ahead keep working for the future
indefinitely
there was no like alternative path
so
i think deep deep down i was seeking
what you wrote about this past week of
basically just trying to be happier
and i didn't know how to get there or
uh i didn't have models i had like role
models of like people i admired who
embodied that state people like seth
godin later in life creative fully alive
and engaged with the world i had no idea
how to get there though it's just his
existence was like that's possible that
seems worth trying to figure out
how do you define success
right now it's something that
probably doesn't make a lot of sense to
people
uh it's basically the space and freedom
and possibility to continue doing the
things that bring me alive or connect me
to who i am
the thing that's interesting obviously
we're both in austin and austin has its
uh share of asceticism and sort of new
age
spirituality
and you know
the pushback against
the default desires the
reprogramming of your wants and needs to
be the things that genuinely do bring
you alive you know this isn't this isn't
anything new but i do think that when
you frame it within
wantrepreneur nomadic internet hustle
culture world i do think that it has a
little bit of a new
slant on it even if perhaps it's moving
in the same direction the language is
very different
agreed i when i left my job i just
wanted to escape work i was very similar
to like fire people
who just want to like
solve life on a spreadsheet and hit exit
right and then we're done with work
we've solved that i don't think that's
how life works so i wanted to escape
work i kind of ran away i tried to limit
the amount of work i was doing at first
i went to these digital nomad locations
i went to beaches where i'd meet like
bitcoin people who did solve the
financial problems or
people who had exited from startups and
had more money than they needed
the thing is nobody actually wants to
sit on a beach
i think what we really want is to be
useful
we want to do work that matters we don't
want to do meaningless work it drives
humans crazy to do stuff we don't care
about
but we all have this desire to do stuff
we want to contribute we want to help
people we want to do things that we feel
like are important
what's your thoughts on the financial
independence retire early movement it's
not really
caught on as much in the uk
i think it
is probably because i think americans
oftentimes don't get that our labor
market is bananas especially at the high
end how do you make for like not for
knowledge work just like strategy
consulting for example my friends i know
in the uk
doing the same thing at the similar
level are just getting paid like 40 50
percent less
right so part of fire is emerging from
just this excess capital both in like
high-wage knowledge professions and also
the tech economy where you're having
people working at google like
making three four hundred thousand
dollars a year so they're just doing the
math and being like well why am i even
working
right but my my take on the fire
movement is
overall net benefit
i think at a surface level though it
sort of misses the point
which i think this is the biggest shift
i've realized is like
escaping work is not
a good motive for life
finding the work you want to keep doing
is a more important motive
i imagine no matter what success you
have
you're not going to lose that curiosity
of talking to people having
conversations exploring ideas that seems
so uniquely like you right you can't
make it to
450 episodes
unless that's like something like very
authentic and
emergent
yeah sometimes i do wish that i could
switch it off i think that my friend my
friends
definitely do if they just want to chill
out and i'm like dude have you ever
wondered about why it is that the sky is
able to be pink and sort of dark at the
same time i want to have you ever
considered about the reason why sugar
tastes shorter uh spikes of sweetness as
opposed to um sucralose which is like a
longer bit
so yeah sometimes i do wish that i could
turn it off however
i think that
the
one of the things i realized upon
reading some of your work about
the financial independence retiree
movement is that
some people don't want to stop working
they just want a break
they don't need to to quit work they've
just maybe pushed it a bit hard for a
while and it does seem
people have a very binary view of a lot
of things and it's like i don't want to
stop or i want to go there's no in
between
right
i think one of the biggest net benefits
to the world might just be a mandated
sabbatical of three months once you hit
your 30s are you saying the mormons have
got it right
perhaps yeah they're doing it at like 18
years old yeah yeah
but they're i don't know i always they
always seem more mature anyway but um we
won't go down that rabbit hole
um
yeah i think i didn't realize this at
first
when i left my job what i realized
quickly
was that i had oriented my life in such
a way that work was the primary mode of
which i thought of myself as a person
and how i related to everything in the
world where i lived who i hung out with
what i did how i spent my time when i
was allowed to take time off was all
dictated downstream of work
and when i left i sort of had a little
more freedom and in that space
like i just had this hunch that like i
needed to lean in even more
and seven months into after leaving my
job i decided to create my own like
non-work sabbatical where i wasn't going
to pursue any
paid work
and what i discovered in that that was
when i started my podcast that's when i
started writing that's when i started
creating online and i just found
absolute joy
in creating these things for the sake of
themselves and then meeting the people
that were like oh hell yeah
and that was the first like hunch i had
and this is before like this whole
current creator economy of like there's
all these paths to make money existed it
was like i had this hunch though like if
i lean in this direction it i could
create a better life for myself
[Music]
what
why do you think it is that so many
people are disappointed with work at the
moment
so i don't even know if so many people
are
it's sort of this catchy
media headline of the great resignation
and
the fact is
uh
anti-work you talked about this with
anna yeah um
i think she has a great perspective on
this because she's gone deep into the
history of this and has a much more
nuanced perspective
but being anti-work broadly there's like
35 on-ramps onto that
anyone who's ever had a bad experience
with a manager ever can be like oh yeah
work sucks and you can relate to that
meme
however when you ask most people do you
like your job
a high majority actually say yes
and people don't like to hear this
i remember i'm not sure how recent these
stats were but um
50 no sorry 70 percent of people
are neither engaged or disengaged with
their work and 15 of people are actively
disengaged with their work so 85 percent
of people were either neutral or
negative now that was a while ago i
think that's a johan hari
stat um
but i i don't know i mean do you think
from your experience that people are
more engaged with their work so i think
it's too broad of a question i i've seen
all the full range of stats like and are
there many people doing pointless things
sure i think one of the things that
put me on my path when i was 18 years
old i had my first internship in a
corporation at a big industrial
manufacturing company and i was just
shocked at all these adults sitting
around doing the most pointless stuff
ever and then me bringing up this fact
and them telling me i was the naive one
i'm like this is a crazy world
right so
i'm actually not interested in the
question of like is work good or bad
what i'm more interested in is like this
deeper level of like how did work become
so central in our lives because that is
the ultimate key of like taking a
sabbatical taking a sabbatical is taking
a pause of existing in the world in the
state of a worker
right so i think people want to break
from living in worker mode
and enable them to like reconnect with
the world reconnect with those
child-like things they do like over and
over again people when they take breaks
they start doing things like they did
when they were a kid they start playing
tennis or basketball or reading or
volunteering or gardening all these
things they did when they had more time
and space in their life
and that reminds them oh oh crap i'm not
a worker
i have these other things and
then that's when people often can start
pricing their time and freedom
appropriately and start making
trade-offs and saying like okay
maybe work isn't going to be perfect
but i can at least figure out what are
the things that matter and not
compromise on them
do you think that most people or a big
chunk of people see their primary source
of value to the world as being
their job or their title or the work
that they do
yeah
why do you think that is i don't think
that's always been the case
yeah i i think
so we're always in relation to our
economic system like
in many ways our economic system
determines like our consciousness
right and whether we want it to be true
or not
the way you acquire most things
food shelter
uh everything you have to pay for those
things right so that's like
an economic system you're part of so
that influences how we think of
everything right we have all these
phrases which we don't even think about
time is money
don't waste your time
right they're economic framings
like even just i'm busy oh i had a
productive sunday oh what did you do on
sunday oh i just did a bunch of laundry
and stuff it's like why are we where are
we calling that productive that's a
little silly
right so we're so influenced by this and
then in western countries like we've
just had hundreds of years of this like
refactoring of work being like a central
aim of life it wasn't until the
president protestant reformation that we
started to look at work
as
the aim
instead of this instrumental thing that
helped us get other things
i think
that's a really important point like
that's a super important point the fact
that you can
bypass
work being a vehicle to get you the
thing that you want presumably which is
the ability to do what you want when you
want with who you want for as long as
you want and no one can tell you
otherwise like money is freedom as far
as i can see that's all it is in it at
its best or wealth is freedom should i
say at its best most sort of pure form
and if work is a vehicle to get that now
some people love their work and some
people can be fulfilled by it but for
the people that aren't
you can forget the fact that you
aren't massively invested into this work
existentially or emotionally
and yet still give it the same sort of
um
fundamental
magnetic tie between you and it right
you become inseparable from your work
despite the fact that it was just
supposed to be a vehicle to serve you
not for you to serve it
i would even say that's sort of a
limited definition of freedom
so money is freedom sure but
people say things like oh i'm
financially independent what does that
really mean it basically means you rely
on paying other people to do stuff for
you
right
so you're only freeing as much as
everyone else continues to operate
in that way
right but that's not actually what leads
to a fulfilling life what leads to a
fulfilling life is like treating a
friend for dinner and not expecting them
to pay you back
you don't want to you literally don't
want to be paying for everything
if you're not receiving gifts and giving
gifts to at least some people in your
life i imagine you're not
as happy as you could be
i'm just
i'm still trying to think about why it
is
that we
see work as so central to who we are
i understand that it's a vehicle to get
us what we need but
it doesn't
tell the whole picture as far as i can
see
well it's
it's not true everywhere right so
there's
max weber in his book the protestant
epic
he writes about how before the
1500s basically like
a person did not desire to like have
work as the most central thing in their
life there was this what he called
traditionalist view of work
and it was okay i've done enough work to
like pay for what i need and i'm done
working
and
early when you read about the early
evolutions of capitalism you read that
this was a huge problem
so how do you set the wages such that
people will continue to work
because they were finding that
they'd pay people and people would say
oh all right i'm good thank you i'm done
with my job
right so
and then you have people like joseph
peeper writing after world war ii uh he
wrote an amazing book laser leisure the
basis of culture
he's contemplating this question and
he's saying
okay we just had these crazy terrible
things happen in the world and now
everyone is just running back and
throwing themselves in as like a worker
and like pretending nothing happened
like why are we doing this and his
conclusion was that was kind of lost
touch with this more ancient version of
leisure
so we sort of have these two modes in
western cultures especially we have the
doing mode and then we have being lazy
and he's arguing that like leisure
is in the middle
of this sort of in between state and i
think this is what i experienced when i
took that like first non-work break
and the definition of leisure is not
laying around and watching netflix
it's defined as like an active
engagement with the
world and
really interesting thing like i covered
this in my book if you go back to the
greeks
the definition for work or like the
phrase they had for work was not at
leisure
so before this whole flip in the
protestant reformation the evolution of
capitalism like leisure was the center
of life it was just taken for granted
and now we've sort of flipped that
but we've paired the opposite of work
with this
laziness so you're either lazy or
working so then like when people say i'm
terrified to stop working they're
terrified of being labeled lazy but they
don't know this in between mode of like
active engagement with the world i would
call i guarantee what you do with
podcasting
does not fit into one of those two
buckets right it's like it's almost like
you have to do it you're so pulled to do
it and i guarantee too like because i
have this experience with writing if you
don't do it for a few weeks you feel
like something's missing in your life
does that resonate yeah absolutely that
um knotted leisure
uh insight about the greeks is
phenomenal and it highlights
exactly how
backward
i think fundamentally people
have a sense that the work world is
that they're living to work
and that a lot of their time is spent
obsessing over their job
now obviously what
what you're trying to do or what most
people are trying to do is repurpose
their job into something that they don't
mind obsessing over
which is fine you know if you can get
yourself to this stage where um my
housemate right so he's a physio for
newcastle falcons rugby club so premier
league rugby team top flight you know
one of the best in the country
uh and he gets up every day and gets to
go and do that
but even that situation
if he had
unlimited degrees of freedom with how he
was going to spend his time he may
choose something else so it's the best
of a good situation but it's still
within the framework of it being work
now
i totally understand how
not creating a
you're either working or lazy
world
would be very very bad for capitalism
right i'm very hesitant around the
conspiratorial like henry ford and the
vanderbilts got together in the 1900s
and decided to do this thing
i would lean
as an explanation for this much more
toward a either a mimetic or a status
version of an answer that look you see
the people working hard
other people get accolades and are
admired for working hard because you
know that working hard is a proxy for
future success therefore people start
shortcutting the desire for successor
happiness and just goes straight to
working hard because it's a more obvious
signal you think i've got that right
well i think you're on to something i
think the criticisms of capitalism fall
short for me because capitalism isn't
really a thing like it's continuously
evolving and people are reacting to the
incentives that exist in the world
like
i think in many ways you can almost
reframe it as like people like henry
ford what would they have been doing a
thousand years earlier probably leading
a w he'd probably be a warlord
or something yeah yeah yeah
fighting wars with people right instead
he can like channel this like unbridled
ambition into the economic system like
and people can disagree about that but
this is also the challenge with carving
your own path is you can't just
you can't just exit work right like you
can't escape the default reality
existing in the way i am like i'm
self-employed i make income in a number
of different ways i do a bunch of
different things i don't work in
traditional ways i still feel the
tension like it's very obvious i'm a
weirdo
that's why i come to austin to hang out
with all the other weirdos um
but other people judge me based on like
people still say to me like and i make
enough money to support my life and like
i'm doing better and better every year
when are you gonna get a real job
it's like what does that mean
and
and i think what i'm
trying to lean into and open people's
eyes to is like we've sort of gone from
this economic system in the 50s to maybe
the year 2000 in which like the
possibilities for our past like our
lives were not possible then
they are possible now and the
possibilities for creating different
kinds of work and working in different
ways working remotely part-time flexibly
are so much
more
than they were even like 10 20 years ago
but we don't have a script or way of
orienting to the world to like unlock
those possibilities so like i think it's
actually a great thing right now like
some people don't realize it's sort of
low status
to do this like self-employed creator
path
especially like our parents often don't
like what we're doing they wish we do
other things
um
and that's sort of an advantage because
there's just like less competition right
now
it's low status depending on who you're
speaking to right you know if you if you
rock up i went to a the launch of a new
magazine
that was with a bunch of people doing
some mad [ __ ] in crypto like the entire
conversation was over my head everything
was over my head i finally managed to
find one guy that was happy to talk
about baseball to me and i was like you
you it's it's not decentralized baseball
is it right cool come on we mean you can
have a conversation um
but in there you know the
assistant
ag
for
austin
like was was there and lots and lots of
different people but in that group you
know me saying what do you do and you
gotta own a business in the uk and i'm a
podcaster
oh that's interesting tell me what your
podcast about so it is very um
based on who you're speaking to
however
you talk about the the pathless path and
the default path as sort of two
different worlds
are you hoping in future that the
pathless path will no longer be pathless
then that it's going to be well trodden
enough that people actually can see some
alternate um routes that are laid out
for them archetypally they can
previous people have sort of
laid out a route that they can take
i think what i'm trying to convey to
people is it's worth
softening
our grip on the default path what is how
would you define the default path and
what are the problems with it
so the the default path is simply like
the script we grow up with everyone in
almost every country has a story of like
how to be a successful adult and it's
typically like a very surface level
story get a job go to school get married
have a family get a job and like
the problem with these scripts is that
they often only involve events that
happen before the age of 35 and are
categorically positive
so when anything goes wrong or you're
thrown a curveball in life we have no
like story to orient to
so people like double down on like more
security more certainty right except the
path the default path
is not delivering the benefits it once
was
it used to be this like sort of golden
ticket
we had these like two parent households
we have way less two parent households
now
um
this
work at a company they'll take care of
you they'll give you a pension nobody
believes that exists anymore some people
have it very few do
um
and you could kind of afford a home
on a reasonable salary and like buy it
when you're 24 buy your next one who is
27.
that's not really possible as easily
anymore so like that path has gotten a
lot harder we don't have an alternative
story to grip to so we're sort of like
stuck with that and like i think as
we're shifting to this information age
like
we have a lot of people in jobs that are
like i want to escape but they're so
scared
because they don't really have a new
story for like how to orient their life
so like
my bold attempt is like the pathless
path can be your story
and i don't want to convince everyone to
take this i'm really writing for like
the people already on the unconventional
path and saying like hey here's how i'm
making sense of it and how in a way
that's fulfilling and feel sustainable
to me i don't know if this will work for
you beg borrow steal
from all the principles i put out there
and remix it like write your own version
of it too
um
but i've had many people tell me oh wow
i felt like such an idiot for years and
now i don't feel so alone
how can people tell if this is for them
[Music]
the people
the majority of people that reach out to
me and i've had hundreds of curiosity
conversations with people over the last
five years i just have an open calendar
on wednesdays and people can book calls
with me this is how i kind of learn
learn um
the majority of those people
know that the default path won't work
for them
and they just want information
they want different ideas different
paths
and a lot of people just want friends
like the best antidote to feeling like
you're crazy
and not able to fit in the default path
is to find a few friends who are seeing
the world in a similar way or moving in
a similar direction
and that can be enough to kind of give
you a confidence to move in a different
direction but that's often what people
are seeking they just want to feel less
alone
and
that they're not so crazy for trying to
figure out a different way
is the solution then for everyone to
just go work for themselves or work on
their own or go freelance
i don't think so i've talked to a lot of
people
uh
surprising number of people
who
know
they know themselves right this all
starts with self-reflection through
self-reflection i realized i needed an
insane amount of autonomy over the work
i was doing
most people are willing to trade some of
that for like certainty in a paycheck
like jobs are freaking awesome
our current iteration of jobs think
about people 100 years ago they would
have been like hell yeah
you're going to give me a steady
paycheck
i don't have to worry about like the
next uh
the next crop if it's gonna grow or not
um
this is great for a lot of people
right i think
the challenge is a lot of people just
kind of like go through life they raised
in this like the whole purpose of going
to school for the first 15 years is to
then get a job and then you work in a
job for 10 years and people are like
wait this is just we just do this
forever and then we retire and then what
i think a lot of those people who do
figure out how can i reclaim that space
and start leaning into leisure mode
taking those sabbaticals
i even talked to one person who i just i
challenged him i was like have you ever
done anything unplanned during a work
day he's like never in my life
i was like all right here's the
assignment for you what is something you
love doing as a kid he's like i love
just like riding a bike around and
exploring like all right tuesday block
off your calendar put important meeting
and just go do that from like two to
five and it was like a
dramatic shift for him
he's a friend he has no desire to not
work full-time he has big ambitions he
wants a big house he wants like all the
fancy things he knows exactly what he's
the costs he's paying but that was like
enough space for him that he was like oh
crap i've just been like ignoring myself
completely
maybe i should lean into that a little
more and i can be a lot happier
what do you talk about the limits of
ambition obviously a lot of people are
very ambitious this is one of the things
that drives them and
for all that i can um
try to remind people that success
doesn't equal happiness and that you can
shortcut your route to get there maybe
um
ambition is seductive and it makes us
feel fulfilled
and
meaning it might not give us happiness
but it can certainly give us meaning but
you talk about the limits of ambition as
well what are they
have you ever read any of agnes
callard's
never heard of her
she's amazing should be a fantastic
guest so she's written about she's a
philosopher at the university of chicago
she's written about
um
two different ideas
ambition versus aspiration
and she says that ambition is basically
aiming at something which we already
value
right
so i want to be a famous youtuber
we already value being a famous youtuber
so she would argue and
there is space to like learn new things
along the way but she would argue given
that we already know what we val how we
value that and that we value it
currently there's not as much to be
gained on the journey
whereas like an aspirational journey is
like we're aspiring to be a certain sort
of person shift to a different life
stage
um shift to a different mode of being
um
it's a little more vague it's harder to
articulate a lot of people have this
like a deep down like gut instinct of
where they're headed and who they want
to be
and the values instead we don't really
know what we're going to come to value
so one example is like i mean you could
say like i want to be somebody that like
appreciates wine
or actually let's let's go sports cause
like the nerdy um
the nerdy tech people we hang around
with don't talk about sports enough
right so i love basketball i grew up
loving basketball
read everything absorbed it played all
the time know all the players i still
follow the nba closely i just love it
when i watch a game and like
i remember like do you watch the nba i
watched march madness a lot this month
yeah it's been great
so
i watch a game and like sometimes you
just see freaking beauty on a court
right and it's like oh my gosh this is
perfect like i'm in love with watching
this game
and uh
i can't articulate that to someone
you would actually need to spend like an
enormous amount of time learning to come
to appreciate the things i
already appreciate about basketball
and you don't get into learning to
appreciate basketball
um knowing what you value already right
so
applying this to like our life like
mark maron and bill simmons they were
very early in the podcasts
peop almost everyone said podcasts were
stupid bill simmons was at espn and they
were like we don't even want to like
support this or run ads on it
he was in that because there wasn't an
outcome of like being a successful
podcaster
right so there was a lot of space for
like serendipity and like learning to
value different things and he probably
had a really meaningful journey learning
to become a podcaster
compared with like now people are like i
want to be a successful podcaster
they're almost like shortcutting
the space
for
what makes the journey fun
so i i do agree and i think that
although it's not the default path it's
also not a pathless path it's a
non-default but well trodden path that
being said
not everybody and
i'm probably a pretty good example of
this man like i don't have an unlimited
amount of creativity in me you know i
i
like orderliness in my life i like a
degree of predictability it's why um i'd
never be a good trader um because if my
financial assets were getting ragged
around at the mercy of the market i
wouldn't be able to focus on what i was
supposed to do
so
i think that what we're talking or what
it sounds like to me what i've got in my
head is it's kind of like a spectrum so
we have on one side we have default path
on the other side we have truly pathless
path right aspiration um
yes aspiration but
in between that we have sort of varying
degrees of people doing things that are
non-default but well trodden then even
less default and even less well trodden
right down to i'm going to completely
free-throw my free-flow my life into
whatever it is that i want to manifest
yeah i i think for me it's like a
journey of like detaching from like i'm
gonna trade off everything for these
future ideas or like i want to be an
identity i want to be a startup founder
instead like just getting rid of all
those scripts and memes and ideas like
meaningful work and all these things and
like figuring out okay what are the
things that i'm driven to do what are
the things i'm excited to do what are
the things that when i experiment and
try them i keep wanting to do them like
writing is one of those things that
emerged for me i really love it right
now
then once you figure out what you want
to do you can then start leaning back in
the other direction and i think this has
been my journey over the past couple of
years i've kind of like i was so scared
of creating another job for myself when
i left my job
and i had to lean so far in the other
direction
to like distance myself from that and
then through that i gained the
confidence it's like okay now i know
like the mix of activities and things
that drive me and like the things i'm
not willing to do such that i'm probably
not going to burn myself out now i can
lean back more into the ambition
direction right so i wrote a book last
year
right
you have to be a little ambitious
no small task man
it's a crazy thing to do
but um
i knew i liked writing enough that it
was a very natural next step
so i was starting with like what i
enjoyed doing writing the book was
thrilling i loved it i had so much fun
one of the most meaningful creative
projects of my life
i'm guessing that's kind of like a
similar progression for you like i mean
i saw your video with
jordan
it's beautiful
like it's a work of work of art
like that's that's ambition but you're
leaning into somebody you already know
like you it was probably beyond
where you were slightly right challenged
you
but you knew
that was something you wanted to lean
into that was true to you yeah yeah it
is an interesting blend you mentioned
there are words that you use a little
bit which is meaningful work what do you
think about the idea of meaningful work
i think it's not a useful meme for a lot
of people i think i was sort of trapped
so
in 2007 when i was graduating college
google came on the best companies to
work for for the first time
at number one and it was like google is
this amazing place to work bean bag
chairs and free lunches and yoga and i'm
like oh my gosh that's so fun like i
want to have fun and like love my
life um and from the next 10 years i
basically just kept jumping job to job
trying to find that like dream job
what i didn't realize is that it didn't
really matter like what i did it was the
how so it's like the being mode
of like how am i showing up and spending
my time
right i might i have no idea if i would
have liked working at google i like
technology
but would i have liked all the meetings
and like the kind of people i i don't
know
um
some
meaningful work there's this amazing
paper from
uh mit
the mit sloan review it's from the
university of sussex
two researchers looked at what actually
gives people meaning at work
what they found was basically
poignant moments
stressful
moment so like poignant like powerful
moments very specific
um stressful often like crises or like
things they had to push through
um often they didn't realize it was
meaningful unless they like reflected
upon it
so this is not what we think of when we
think of meaningful work when a lot of
people are thinking of meaningful work
they're thinking of google i just want
to be happy i want to be like loving
what i do
what really gives you meaning is
like the book writing process was it was
hard it pushed me it was uncomfortable
it was like
it was
i felt like an imposter like a lot of
times but i pushed through that and kept
figuring it out
um that's like meaningful work
meaningful work i think
it's hard to fit that in like a job
container because in most jobs you have
to do stuff you don't want to do
talk to me obviously that's a creator
journey and you you pivoted from being
in a much more default path to one which
although might be free-flowing is still
kind of creatory what are the trade-offs
between time and money that people need
to make
when they get exposed to a create a
journey
i think for me the relationship between
time and money flipped
so
when you're working full-time you sort
of have a salary
and then you like
you're basically an accountant for your
life you're like all right monthly
salary i'm gonna budget this out
um
whereas
this seems so obvious now but it was
shocking to me a couple months after
quitting it was like
my first couple of months i didn't make
any money and i was quickly realizing
everything i spent
i had to earn
right it's like oh this great ramen
place down the street i was living in
new york city when i left my job it's
like 22
it's like maybe i don't want that
like maybe i don't want to work the
thirty dollars to earn that bowl of
ramen right do i really value that
uh bowl of ramen and like eating out
every night so it sort of made me like
refactor and revalue everything i was
spending my time my money on so
like instead of saying okay i have this
bucket of money i'm just gonna spend it
i don't care what the hell i do it was
like everything was like i was auditing
every expense of my life okay is this
bringing me value
and what i started to realize is that i
just really valued my free time
i valued it at such a high amount that i
was willing to lower costs
in other aspects of my life
and i just kept leaning into that space
so
and i still think this way everything i
do it's like okay if i'm gonna join a
gym and pay 200 a month what does that
actually mean that means i have to earn
an incremental like
three or four grand a year to pay for
that is that worth the trade-off
or can i leave that space open
of work i would otherwise have to like
push for try to get consulting gigs for
to leave that for creative projects
so the work worth doing for me is like
the writing i love the writing but
writing doesn't really pay the bills
so i want to protect that space for the
writing though and like creating and
podcasting and doing these experiments
because over the long run over the next
25 years i know those are the things
that are going to energize my life and
make it worth living
does that story from
the e-myth revisited uh about a lady who
starts baking cakes i think so there's
this woman who loves baking loves making
cakes decides that she's gonna start
doing it and then just the classic
solopreneur journey some of her friends
want her to bake cakes for birthdays
then she starts doing weddings then she
decides that she's going to get a little
store so she gets a store and then she
gets some staff because she needs some
staff to work at the store and she's
baking but then she spends a bit less
time baking because she needs to money
to the staff and she needs to make sure
that the accounts are done and then she
gets super super popular so she gets an
even bigger store and then she gets a
deal to be able to start selling these
to supermarkets and before you know it
she doesn't even remember what the smell
of a cake is like she hasn't baked in
months and she spends all of her time
managing and doing stuff and i think
that again this unbridled ambition that
people have
takes them often takes them away from
the thing that they actually want to do
and you even see this like forget
all the existential meaning
conversations think about it from a pure
business perspective that a lot of the
time in a sales organization a great
salesperson naturally wants to
move up
but that great sales person might not be
a tremendously good manager so you
lose a good salesperson gain a shitty
manager that person no longer has
mastery over the things that they do
they're not built to do that but because
we have this sort of single vector of i
need to be moving forward i must
progress like this um
and i think that trying to offer people
alternatives of look how can you take
this skill set and perhaps move it
elsewhere there's never been as much
opportunity for you to go and do things
and again we're speaking to a very
specific type of person here right you
know it's not it's not the person who
has a bunch of responsibilities and i
need to i've got to put food on the
table for the family and stuff like that
like you know do what you got to do like
if you've got to get that grind done
then sweet
but for the people that this does
resonate with that say
i do think that maybe i
i'm built to do something different than
i am now
i have this
disgruntled unsatisfactory burbling
somewhere inside of me
but maybe they're lacking courage or
bravery or direction or a first step
what would you say to those people
practical steps or just
um things to
lean into in themselves that's going to
give them that that bravery and that
courage to decide to do something a bit
different
the reason i wrote my book is that the
stories i read about people quitting
their job
were
fake
like they were too simple and i've
noticed this impulse in myself and it's
why i started writing about it a few
years ago is that when people ask tell
me about the moment you decided to quit
your job and then all of a sudden you're
like oh maybe this moment and then i had
the courage to leap
my experience was a slow fumbling
towards quitting my job of like slow and
painful years of realizations
silly experiments that didn't quite make
sense unless i looked back
and then all of a sudden i reached a
point in which it was like obvious to
quit
but even like as i was quitting i i
didn't have this like idea that like i
was headed towards something else right
so
i think what i often have people do is
like
i did this in a course i used to run um
have people do an action challenge
what's something in a week that can get
you out of your comfort zone
that might give you some information
about what to do next
so i call this approach ship quit and
learn
so basically do something
design it for quitting
so you're not dealing with like getting
caught up with like the end state or
definitions of success and the only
point is to learn what to do next give
us an example
so if you want to start a podcast
buy a mic
sit down with yourself and record an
episode for 10 minutes
saying why you want to do a podcast
and publish it
and then just see how it feels
and then figure out
what do you do next
right and i think people miss this like
they probably look at you with the
podcast
and they're like i have to have the same
setup as him it's like no go back to his
first episode he's sitting around with
his buddies sucks
it's beautiful though because that's how
everyone starts this is the great thing
about the internet is you can see you
can see the full trajectory yes dude i
say this all the time you know you can
go back and watch rogan
on exactly potato
yeah it's awful he's like the first 10
minutes of it is him trying to get the
internet to work and they're looking at
the
they can't work out if it's going on
you're you're way way way ahead of where
joe rogan was when he started and look
at where he is now yeah that's that's a
really good thing i also very much
appreciate the
um open honesty around it not being a
fairy tale penny drop
about anything people ask these
questions i remember love island they
used to say stuff like uh so what's your
type
and what they what they meant by what's
your type is what are the narrowly
defined physical characteristics that
you look for in a girl i'm like dude who
answers this question with like yeah
it's like brunettes with blonde eyes and
she's got to be at this thing and i'm
like who who genuinely who has this
like low resolution view of the world or
the same for people say man so
when did you know that you wanted to
start doing club promoting or you wanted
to start a podcast i i
i don't know
i don't know like we we don't exist
maybe sometimes we encounter a situation
which is so traumatic or so grand or so
beautiful or or inspiring us or
life-changing that it causes us to just
orthogonally go oh [ __ ] i wasn't ready
for that but it's so rare
it's so rare things we are the product
of tiny incremental changes that
compound over time
it's the same as asking somebody when
did you get old like one day at a time
the
the thing is i think people can
prototype these changes too and i think
people
mistakenly like to take a creator solo
entrepreneurial path even like exploring
different kinds of work
the scripts of the default path tell us
that we need to
get access before we can do the thing
right we need permission from a
gatekeeper we apply to a job such that
we can then do the job
the reality of the world now is we can
often just start
and instead of aiming at like an
identity a lot of people like this whole
creator path is like
now legible whereas like i'm talking to
people
at big tech companies and like i want to
be a creator and i'm like well what do
you create it's like well i want to
write i'm like have you written anything
they're like no i'm like you should test
that first
you should like give yourself a one
month challenge and see if you write
every day for a month do you actually
like that
um
and that was what i had been doing
without knowing it on the side like i
was writing on quora for fun and i was
writing publicly and then people were
reaching out based on what i was
reaching out
and like i was really just practicing
the things that i would eventually end
up doing but i i didn't leave with like
oh i'm gonna become a writer or
creator yeah realizing
realizing the price that you pay to do
the thing that you want to do is a a
pretty important insight because a lot
of the time you know being a rock star
sounds fantastic
but touring whatever shitty country
you're from in the back of a cheap
campervan
for
five years
barely earning enough money with no
promise that this is going to work
and having to master your own records
and having to learn about mixing down
like dude it's not standing on a stage
and playing songs it's arguing with your
bandmates over who's going to drive the
van home like that's the reality of
being in a rock band and
i'm i'm close with
the guys from bring me the horizon and
like hearing them talk about the first
few years of them and they got they rose
to pretty quick prominent fame
and even with them
the first few years are like
unbelievably
primitive
and they've just released a song with
machine gun kelly and ed sheeran in the
space of a month
amazing
and that's the world that they started
in and you go okay like conor mcgregor
as well you know maybe less so now
because he's kind of gone a bit mental
again but
the conor mcgregor of five years ago
when he was king of the world
people looked at that and said yeah i
want that and you go okay well
what do you think that was like for him
living in his parents attic on
irish
like job seekers allowance
with his misses no idea if it was going
to work rolling the same sequences day
after day throwing the same combinations
day after day endless drills endless
training sessions living on benefits
like is that
that's that's what it is that's his life
that's the life that it is and it's only
in retrospect when you can see success
that anything
that glory is to be found in those first
instances
um
so yeah i think working out
trying to find that intersection of a
price that you would be willing to pay
yeah that's a good place to start i was
calculating how much income i probably
gave up over the last five years
of stepping off this path i'm pretty
it's conservatively a million dollars
but
in my
so my first like six months i did
freelancing and i proved like okay i can
make money i can make this work and then
i was quickly drawn to like this creator
stuff
and over the next 18 months i made about
20 000.
and i was like barely making ends meet i
was burning down savings i moved abroad
to save money i was like so anxious
about finances
but i in those months found work worth
doing
and after that i was basically willing
to go to war to protect that opportunity
that seems like
that matters like and i think i wrote my
book because i want to tell people that
like
if you find this stuff and you think
it's important that matters
will you be able to get
will you be able to get paid for it i
don't know
i don't know how to do that i'm not a
rock star hyper ambitious person that
can just monetize everything
but might it lead you to a life that is
energizing where you feel alive where
you feel connected
it might and
it might suck in the short term but it
might also be worth it
two things that i've got in my mind
first one is a lot of people that i know
are converging on this same stuff you
know that blog post of mine was before
i'd read your book
and yet it converges perfectly look at
chris sparks man chris former yeah
online number four poker player on the
planet productivity coach like he
literally
he sharpens the bleeding edge of the
most ambitious people on the planet
professionally that's his job
and yet you speak to him and it's like
talking to some
zen master that's just come back from a
cave all of us are
relinquishing the
trappings
that kept us imprisoned before
the things that we thought we wanted
yeah it's funny talking to chris
uh he sort of hijacks you he uses the
language of like the default ambitious
world he's like goals i'd i've always
had like an issue with goals i'm like
but then you read deeper you're like
oh chris is chris is saying the same
thing i am
slightly different language
and
he's even deeper because he's going to
like these depths of like values and
like what really matters and like
using it to harness people's
like natural drive so there
there's nothing wrong with like
ambitious goals i i know myself i'm less
ambitious
than other people like we both know ali
abdel right
i don't have his level of ambition but
i'm smart enough to know that i don't
have that genetic setting
yes he's a he's a machine but like he's
so happy doing what he loves yes
right
but it's figuring out like
how what is that setting for you through
like trial and error it's also figuring
out
look
is that what i want or is that what i
want because other people seem to want
it because psychological contagion is a
hell of a drug man and mimetic desire
will carry you a long
long way because it's easy to look at
someone like ali who's his course will
be bringing in
three mil four mil probably a year at
[ __ ] knows maybe 85 percent margin maybe
more you know like it's all it's
internet stuff it's all money it's all
profit um plus he's got his youtube
channel plus he's got a book coming out
soon plus all of the sponsors on his
podcast and blah blah blah
and you go dude that's that's great but
like he is a one in a
one in ten thousand one in a hundred
thousand freak who has a very particular
blend that has allowed him to do this um
is that genuinely what you want and is
that the price that you're prepared to
pay for it
and
looking at
success and what it means to you
starting from a value-led
my
contribution to the world what i know
about myself that sort of reflection
starting from that position i think
it's very difficult to go wrong because
you go
what you said earlier on you know a
million uh dollars over the space of
five years i mean that that's like toe
curling [ __ ]
painful
but the
point is that
if that's not what you value and if you
value the things that you're doing now
more then that's a price that's worth
paying here was the other thing i wanted
to say about that as well
in retrospect a lot of the time we
forget why we did the things we did
so looking back
and saying i could have earned a million
dollars over five years a million
dollars more um
you can say well i would love a million
dollars but you forget why you didn't
earn a million dollars my point is that
the person that we are in the moment and
the person that we are in retrospect are
very very different and that's so
important like
um i wish that i hadn't drank last night
everybody says that the next day but you
go well did you enjoy
did you did you enjoy the party well
yeah okay well maybe you maybe this
isn't the case maybe this is just your
frame of reference right now
yeah
i when i look back
i actually couldn't continue working in
that job i had reached a breaking point
i had burned out and i think one of the
advantages i've had on my current path
is that i burned out
and i had reached some level of success
that i sort of knew like that wasn't
what i wanted i didn't want to be
trading my time for some future payoffs
in other people's eyes i wanted to find
that internal
driver of success because i had a hunch
it would be more sustainable
that has mostly panned out
and
i now just like
i'm
mistrust i don't trust like automatic
success memes i've been doing online
courses since 2018.
then i see people like
dave and thiago de perel and thiago
forte for people like they're hyper
ambitious and
they're amazing like they've really
leveled up the whole ecosystem of like
what these courses could look like my
wife's and how much money you can earn
from them from their side as well not
just the experience of the student but
the uh monetization of the creator
yeah and so i've been doing courses and
like i'm running a course teaching
consulting skills and i'm making good
money um
but it
it was very easy for me to know oh i'm
not them i don't have that level of
ambition how can i design the thing to
fit within my life
so i love like one-on-one helping people
i love it so i designed like my course
before this podcast i was on a
one-on-one coaching call seeing that
like individual improvement it just like
fires me up i love it and that's
sustainable for me over the long term
but if i'm running like a larger thing
and like have to have employees and
contractors and like
i'm gonna light it on fire
and just like burn it to the ground
after i do it it's the e-myth story
right
um
so i think this is also an advantage of
a solo self-employed creator path is
that
if you do go into an ambitious mode that
isn't your path you'll probably burn out
faster yeah
whereas in a job i think where people
get really stuck and can do harm to
themselves is they maintain this
low-grade burnout
for a long time
whereas like on the solo path you're
just gonna blow it all up because you're
either gonna go too hard and you're
ultimately responsible there's no one to
lean back on either
yeah exactly i think this is something
that i've been playing with for
a long time and i might try and write
about it this week after this
conversation um
not having boundless ambition
is so uncelebrated
in the modern world
everyone and this isn't just your
quintessential garyvee's it's the
subtext of how did you spend your sunday
oh i had a productive sunday i folded
loads of laundry and got this done
it's there is always more ambition to
chase after yeah
and increasingly
i'm seeing in myself and in the people
that i talk to about this stuff that
realizing
matching the amount of ambition that you
have with the sort of life that you live
is the solution
yeah that's that's precisely where your
highest point of contribution
uh can be deployed because you're not
going to burn yourself out
and
just because
david perrell can do
three or four cohorts of rite of passage
every year
and write
huge blog posts and create a documentary
about porter robinson and
be a teal fellow or whatever the [ __ ]
else it is that he's doing or ali can do
the podcast on the youtube and the
courses and the book and whatever like
if that's not you
fine
yeah honestly fine because there are
prices that you would have to pay to get
yourself to that level and you're
probably not prepared to pay them and
just because other people say that
the that level
of aggression
is
something that you should aspire to
doesn't mean that you should
and it doesn't always feel good i know
i'm leaving money on the table sometimes
and i feel silly sometimes
i know i'm capable of more if i really
pushed
but i'm sort of making a bet that that's
not the thing so i have an exercise for
you too you could try have you ever
written like
i so in my book like i'm inspired by
paul jarvis he wrote the company of one
he has this famous blog
post called enough
so i basically just wrote a paragraph of
like what is enough
trying to like hold myself
responsible i grab i can read it if you
want if you want me to read that
so
um
yeah so also derek sivers quote amazing
on this are you helping people are they
happy are you happy are you profitable
isn't that
enough it's like so good
but
i
so like i feel
like okay i'm leaving money on the table
which means i have two choices i can
either go do that because i feel bad or
i can go deeper within myself and figure
out what i really want
so like
i try to just reflect and like i'm
always revisiting these things and
redoing it so like for me this is like
enough is knowing that no amount in my
bank account will ever satisfy my
deepest fears it's knowing that i have
enough friends that would gladly open
their door and share a meal if i was
ever in need it's the feeling that i've
been able to spend my time over an
extended stretch of time working on
projects that are meaningful to me
helping people with a spirit of
generosity and having space and time in
my life to stay energized to keep doing
this over the long term
enough is seeing a clear opportunity
that will increase my earnings in the
short term but knowing that saying no
will open me up to things that might be
even more valuable in ways that are hard
to understand enough is knowing that the
close fancy meal or latest gadget will
not make me happier but also buying such
things won't mean i'm going to end up
broke
enough is having meaningful
conversations with people that inspire
me people that i love or people that
support me
dude
what a way to finish let's leave it
there paul miller ladies and gentlemen
if people want to buy the book or find
out what you do online where should they
go yeah
thinkdashboundless.com or just google
paul millard i'm pretty easy to find
only one with an internet presence nice
pathless path will be linked in the show
notes below as well dude i really
appreciate what you do i appreciate you
thank you for making me feel very
welcome here in austin as well
i'm looking forward to catching up soon
awesome thanks chris what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace